In the 1830s, the area around Niagara Falls was still mostly wilderness. Railroads were just coming in, and already people were complaining about how commercialization was ruining Niagara Falls. Already there were cheesy attempts to make money off tourism. In 1827, promoters sent a ship full of animals over the falls. They had advertised that it would be ferocious animals of the forest-- panthers, wildcats, wolves. Instead, the cargo included a buffalo, two foxes, a raccoon, a dog, and 15 geese. It didn't matter. Everybody made money. The town of Niagara Falls had barely been settled for two decades.
在19世纪30年代，尼亚加拉大瀑布周边地区大多还是荒野。铁路才刚开始延伸，人们就已经在抱怨商业化正在破坏尼亚加拉大瀑布了。当时已经出现了通过旅游业赚钱的庸俗手段。1827年，推广者们把一艘载满动物的船推下了瀑布。他们曾打广告称船上会有森林里的猛兽——美洲豹、野猫、狼。但实际上，船上的货物包括一头水牛、两只狐狸、一只浣熊、一条狗和15只鹅。这无所谓。每个人都赚到了钱。尼亚加拉瀑布城当时建市还不到二十年。
This kind of exploitation of the falls has continued for nearly two centuries since then. And what's surprising about it really is how unsuccessful it's been. Power plants fell into the river. Bridges collapsed. Deals were struck that benefited no one. If the classic story of America is the story of people who started with nothing, pulled themselves up by their bootstraps, made something of themselves, the story of Niagara Falls is the opposite story. Here, they started with something, something big, something huge, but didn't build anything lasting from it.
这种对瀑布的开发，在过去近两个世纪里一直持续着。真正令人惊讶的是，这种开发一直以来有多么不成功。发电厂掉进了河里。桥梁坍塌。达成的协议对谁都没有好处。如果说美国的经典故事是关于那些一无所有、白手起家、最终有所作为的人的故事，那么尼亚加拉大瀑布的故事则恰恰相反。在这里，人们起步时拥有资源，而且是庞大、巨大的资源，但却没能用它建造任何持久的东西。
The modern history of Niagara Falls can be divided roughly into three phases-- the schemers who came in trying to exploit the falls for tourism, how their dreams rose and fell. But that's not the story we're here to tell today. Then there were the schemers who came in trying to exploit the falls for industry. By the twentieth century, they built hydroelectric power plants and factories that used that power, that cheap power, moved in. But then those factories left, decimated by the same economic forces that ravaged the industries in most of the Rust Belt states, forces so powerful they can destroy a town, even a town with one of the world's natural wonders in it.
尼亚加拉大瀑布的现代史大致可以分为三个阶段：第一阶段是那些试图利用瀑布发展旅游业的投机者，他们的梦想起起落落。但那不是我们今天要讲的故事。接着是那些试图利用瀑布发展工业的投机者。到了二十世纪，他们建造了水力发电厂，工厂也利用这种廉价的电力搬了进来。但后来这些工厂离开了，它们被同样的经济力量摧毁，而这种力量也蹂躏了大多数铁锈地带州的工业。这些力量如此强大，以至于它们能摧毁一座城镇，哪怕是一座拥有世界自然奇观之一的城镇。
But that's not the story we're here to tell today either. We're here to tell the story of the third phase of Niagara's life-- the people who live in the aftermath of those dreams that have been dreamt and lost, who live in present day Niagara Falls, a city like many cities around the country, blessed at some point with natural advantages and resources that somehow fell from grace, fell apart, a town full of people trying to make sense of what's happened, living in the aftermath of what's happened, some who've made their peace with what Niagara is, some who haven't.
但这也不是我们今天要讲的故事。我们要讲的是尼亚加拉生活的第三个阶段——那些生活在梦想破碎后的残局中的人们，他们生活在现今的尼亚加拉瀑布城。这座城市就像全国各地的许多城市一样，曾经拥有得天独厚的自然优势和资源，但却不知何故失宠、分崩离析。这里住满了试图理解所发生的一切的人，生活在余波之中，有些人已经与尼亚加拉的现状和解，有些人则没有。
During the next half hour, we're going to bring you two sets of stories interlaced, half of them from documentary producer Alix Spiegel, who went to the falls and interviewed people living there, half from David Kodeski, who grew up in the town of Niagara Falls. It's This American Life, from WBEZ Chicago, Public Radio International, I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
在接下来的半小时里，我们将为您带来两组交织的故事，一半来自纪录片制片人爱丽丝·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel），她去瀑布采访了住在那里的人们；另一半来自大卫·科德斯基（David Kodeski），他在尼亚加拉瀑布城长大。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），我是主持人艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
All the stories this hour will be from Alix and David. We'll start with this one from Alix.
本节目的所有故事都将来自爱丽丝和大卫。我们先从爱丽丝的这个故事开始。
There's a painting of Niagara above the couch in Paul's living room and another on the opposite wall over a chair. These pictures have a romantic, epic feel, like the two Niagara pictures he's hung on the wall near the front door. Then there are the four aerial photographs of the falls above the greenhouse window and the etchings of the falls in his office and the small, delicate portrait of the falls in the kitchen over the sink. There is in fact a picture of Niagara on almost every wall of every room in Paul's house. I visit Paul, and we sit together on the couch in his living room under the biggest picture of blue water rushing the brink. He's wearing his Niagara baseball cap.
保罗的客厅沙发上方挂着一幅尼亚加拉的油画，对面墙上一把椅子上方还有一幅。这些画有一种浪漫而史诗般的感觉，就像他挂在正门附近墙上的那两幅尼亚加拉画作一样。此外，温室窗户上方还有四张瀑布的航空摄影照片，书房里有瀑布的蚀刻画，厨房水槽上方还有一幅精致的小型瀑布肖像。事实上，保罗家的每个房间的每面墙上几乎都有尼亚加拉的画。我拜访保罗时，我们坐在客厅的沙发上，头顶就是那幅巨大的蓝色水流冲向悬崖边缘的画。他戴着自己的尼亚加拉棒球帽。
Walking towards the falls you can notice the crescendo building up, the change. Then you can hear this mmmmmm, and that sound of the falls as you're getting closer and closer and closer. And finally you're there. It's like the "1812 Overture," when the symbols go, boom! Dum-da-da-dum! I get goosebumps when I hear that every time I hear it. Honest to God. If you've ever heard the "1812 Overture," I'm sure. Well, that's the same feeling. That's what people should get when they go to Niagara-- goosebumps.
走向瀑布时，你会注意到声音渐强，发生了变化。然后你可以听到这种“嗯……”的声音，随着你越走越近，那种瀑布的声音也越来越响。最后你到了那里。这就像《1812序曲》中，当铜钹响起的时候，轰！咚哒哒咚！每次听到那段，哪怕我只是听听，都会起鸡皮疙瘩。说真的，我向上帝发誓。如果你听过《1812序曲》，我相信你也一样。好吧，就是那种感觉。这才是人们来到尼亚加拉时应该感受到的——起鸡皮疙瘩。
Paul was a schoolteacher but retired early so he could study and write about Niagara full time. He's written five books, a folder of poems and gives lectures to local high schools and environmental groups. Nothing about the falls is too small for Paul to study. He is, for example, the only person ever to compile a comprehensive history of suicides at the falls. He did this by combing through a century's worth of newspapers at the local library, picking out all the articles and references to suicide, and collecting this information in a series of graphs, colored bar charts on poster board, which break the suicides down by age, sex, and so on.
保罗曾是一名教师，但提前退休以便全职研究和撰写关于尼亚加拉的内容。他写了五本书，还有一文件夹诗歌，并给当地高中和环保组织举办讲座。对保罗来说，关于瀑布的一切都没有小事。例如，他是历史上唯一汇编了瀑布自杀全面历史的人。他通过梳理当地图书馆一个世纪以来的报纸，挑选出所有关于自杀的文章和参考资料，并将这些信息收集在一系列图表、海报板上的彩色柱状图中，按年龄、性别等对自杀事件进行了细分。
Monday, blue Monday, I guess is the most popular day. Wednesday is the least popular. Over the hump. People always feel good. Over the hump. Weekend's coming, so who wants to do away with themselves? We got the weekend coming. And then what time of the day are suicides? 4 o'clock in the afternoon. So tired of work. Can't stand it. Can't decide to go home or whatever. And then what month of the year? September is the most. And believe it or not, the next month is the least, October.
星期一，忧郁的星期一，我想这是最热门的一天。星期三是最冷门的。度过了周中。人们总是感觉不错。度过了周中。周末快到了，所以谁想去寻死呢？周末就在眼前。那么一天中什么时间自杀最频繁？下午4点。工作太累了。忍受不了了。决定不了是回家还是怎样。那么一年中的哪个月？九月最多。信不信由你，下个月十月是最少的。
Paul reads me a poem he wrote called "Sensing the Wonders of Niagara." He tells me that the American Falls and the area around the American Falls is supposed to be a natural reserve according to a hundred years of New York state law. But, he says, the city of Niagara doesn't care. He says there are too many skyscrapers, too much honky-tonk, too many factories, and tourist helicopters buzzing low all day long. On the Canadian side of the falls, there's casino gambling and wax museums and sushi.
保罗为我朗读了他写的一首诗，题为《感知尼亚加拉的奇迹》。他告诉我，根据纽约州一百年的法律，美国瀑布及其周边地区本应是自然保护区。但是，他说，尼亚加拉市根本不在乎。他说那里摩天大楼太多，乱七八糟的娱乐场所太多，工厂太多，还有旅游直升机整天低空轰鸣。在瀑布的加拿大一侧，有赌场、蜡像馆和寿司店。
Then Paul starts asking me questions, not the kind I'm supposed to answer. The kind that answer themselves. Who are we, the residents on either side of this wonder, to think that it is ours to do with as we wish? Why do we insist on introducing more and more buildings and distractions around the falls? Why must we turn the falls into a commodity? How come so many people are so unhappy today? Why are people angry when they drive? Isn't this because there are no places of natural beauty where people can escape modern life?
然后保罗开始问我问题，不是那种需要我回答的问题。而是那些不言自明的问题。我们这些作为奇观两侧居民的人，有什么资格认为我们可以随意对待它？为什么我们坚持在瀑布周围引入越来越多的建筑物和干扰？为什么我们必须把瀑布变成一种商品？为什么今天有这么多人如此不快乐？为什么人们开车时会感到愤怒？难道不是因为这里没有人们可以逃离现代生活的自然美景之地吗？
How would it look if you stood in line at the Louvre in Paris to see the Mona Lisa, as I did in 1979, how would it be if when you finally got to see it there were neon lights all around it, flashing. Buy this. Buy that. Buy this. Could you really enjoy the painting? No. If you went to hear Mozart-- oh, my favorite composer, Mozart. If you wanted to hear Mozart and went to a concert, and you've waited for months to hear this concert and then, right next to the stage was a rock band playing at the same time, could you enjoy the Mozart? I'm afraid not. So when you come to see Niagara Falls, you should see something natural. When you come to hear Niagara Falls, you should hear something natural.
如果你在巴黎卢浮宫排队看《蒙娜丽莎》，就像我1979年做的那样，如果你终于看到它时，周围全是闪烁的霓虹灯，写着“买这个”、“买那个”，你会作何感想？你真的能欣赏那幅画吗？不能。如果你去听莫扎特——哦，我最喜欢的作曲家莫扎特。如果你想听莫扎特，去听音乐会，而且你已经等待了几个月，然后在舞台旁边同时有一支摇滚乐队在演奏，你能欣赏莫扎特吗？恐怕不行。所以当你来看尼亚加拉大瀑布时，你应该看到自然的东西。当你来听尼亚加拉大瀑布时，你应该听到自然的声音。
Paul writes letters to the Niagara Gazette and the Buffalo News, and speaks out at town meetings about limiting commercialization of the area around the falls. His opinions are unpopular. He's seen as an outsider, an extremist. He's been called a complainer and anti-industry. One city councilman told one of his friends that he'd like to see Paul disappear. In 1983, Paul was testifying against a landfill that he thought might threaten the Niagara River. And that night he was woken up at three in the morning by the sound of a truck in his driveway.
保罗给《尼亚加拉公报》和《布法罗新闻》写信，并在城镇会议上大声疾呼限制瀑布周边的商业化。他的观点不受欢迎。他被视为局外人、极端分子。他被称为爱抱怨的人和反工业者。一位市议员曾告诉他的一个朋友，他希望看到保罗消失。1983年，保罗为一个他认为可能威胁尼亚加拉河的垃圾填埋场作证。那天晚上，他被车道上的卡车声音吵醒，当时是凌晨三点。
A truck pulled up in my driveway and put a large metal sawhorse against my overhead garage door. And my dog was barking. I got up, and I just got to see the truck leaving my driveway. And there were two men on the back of the pickup truck and a man driving. And there were two blinking amber lights on the sawhorse. I put my coat on, went outside, and I took a look at it. I said, my god, why is this here? So I called the police. And the sheriff came to my house. And he said Mr. Gromosiak, you've been warned. I said, by whom? He said, I don't know, but that's how they warn people. I said, oh, really?
一辆卡车停在我的车道上，把一个大型金属锯架靠在我的车库门上。我的狗在叫。我起床，正好看到卡车离开我的车道。皮卡车后面有两个人，一个司机。锯架上有两个闪烁的琥珀色灯。我穿上外套，走到外面，看了一眼。我说，天哪，为什么这东西会在这里？于是我报了警。警长来到我家。他说，格罗莫西亚克（Gromosiak）先生，你被警告了。我说，被谁？他说，我不知道，但这就是他们警告人的方式。我说，哦，真的吗？
As a kid, Paul would visit Niagara three or four times a week. He would sit on his favorite stump, watch the water, and fantasize about what his life would be like. But now Paul doesn't visit Niagara at all. He lives less than three miles from the falls, studies and writes about the falls every day, covers his walls with pictures of the falls, but he can't bring himself to go.
小时候，保罗每周会去尼亚加拉三四次。他会坐在他最喜欢的树桩上，看着水流，幻想自己的生活会是什么样子。但现在保罗根本不去尼亚加拉了。他住的地方离瀑布不到三英里，每天研究和撰写关于瀑布的文章，墙上贴满了瀑布的照片，但他就是无法让自己去那里。
For relaxation, I can't anymore. I just can't. I get upset now. I could cry. I feel like I'm walking on the ruins of a wonder. So I go other places to walk.
为了放松，我再也不能去了。我就是不能。我现在会很难过。我可能会哭。我觉得自己好像走在奇迹的废墟上。所以我去其他地方散步。
When you think about your life in the future, do you ever think that you will be able to--
当你思考未来的生活时，你是否认为你能够——
No. No. No, I can't. I don't think I will. I will only go there when I have to, to do a favor for someone or to take people there to see it. But I will remind them about what it was.
不。不。不，我不能。我不认为我会。我只会在必须去的时候才去，为了帮别人一个忙，或者带人去看它。但我会提醒他们它曾经是什么样子。
Paul tells me that he sometimes thinks that fighting for the falls is his destiny. He never married and lives alone, so he has plenty of time to really pursue it. And ultimately, he believes he will see a natural Niagara Falls-- one day-- when he gets to heaven.
保罗告诉我，他有时认为为瀑布而战是他的宿命。他从未结婚，独自居住，所以他有充足的时间真正去追求它。最终，他相信他会看到自然的尼亚加拉大瀑布——有一天——当他去天堂的时候。
Could you imagine being in that place forever, how it used to be with the bald eagle soaring above, hundreds of them, with that ground shaking, with the trees bending over the gorge, growing larger than most other places in North America, all kinds of food to eat? Just cup your hands together and put them in the water and drink it while you're looking at the falls. I can deal with that forever. I can deal with that forever.
你能想象永远在那片土地上，像过去那样，白头鹰在上方翱翔，数以百计，大地震动，树木在峡谷上空弯曲，长得比北美其他大多数地方都要高大，有各种各样的食物可以吃吗？只需把手合拢，伸进水里，看着瀑布喝下去。我可以永远那样生活。我可以永远那样生活。
There are really only two kinds of jobs at Niagara-- heavy industry and tourism. I got a job in tourism. Early in the spring of 1986, I was hired by Gray Line Tours, Incorporated, licensed by the state of New York and the province of Ontario. I had to pass a couple of simple tests. The Canadian, or Horseshoe Falls, are 158 feet high. The American Falls are 184 feet high and have a crest line of 1,060 feet. 30,000 cubic feet of water pass over both falls every minute during the daylight hours in the summer months. The water at the base of the falls is as deep as the falls are high.
尼亚加拉的工作其实只有两种——重工业和旅游业。我找到了一份旅游业的工作。1986年春天，我被灰狗旅游公司（Gray Line Tours, Incorporated）录用，该公司获得了纽约州和安大略省的许可。我必须通过几个简单的测试。加拿大瀑布，或称马蹄瀑布，高158英尺。美国瀑布高184英尺，顶线长1,060英尺。夏季白昼期间，每分钟有30,000立方英尺的水流过两道瀑布。瀑布底部的水深与瀑布的高度相当。
I became Niagara Parks commission tour guide number 674. All that spring, summer, and fall, I drove van loads of tourists to all points of interest in the region. Every tour a three-hour tour, three times a day, 21 times a week. Did you go on the boat, I'm often asked. Yes, I went on the boat three times a day, 21 times a week.
我成了尼亚加拉公园委员会第674号导游。整个春、夏、秋三季，我开着装满游客的货车前往该地区的各个名胜景点。每次行程三小时，每天三次，每周21次。人们常问我，你坐过那艘船吗？是的，我每天坐三次船，每周坐21次。
Today, I know that in family photo albums in India and Japan there are pictures of me pointing out a geologic feature, telling a tale of daredevilry, posed with the rest of the tour group, the natural wonder in the background providing the perfect backdrop.
今天，我知道在印度和日本的家庭相册里，有我指着地质特征的照片，讲述着特技表演的故事，与旅游团的其他成员合影，背景中的自然奇观提供了完美的衬托。
When I was a kid we visited the falls often, nearly every weekend, usually just before Sunday supper at grandma and grandpa's. Yet I never really got over my terror of the falls. Despite the fact that I led tours at Niagara Falls three times a day every day for a single summer, I never got over my terror of them. The water there is so swift, the drop so sudden. You can't stand there at the brink-- watching the water roll over, changing yet always the same-- you can't stand there without the thought crossing your mind. It would be so easy, so peaceful, to just jump. And it does happen. Often. Everyone who lives here has a story of someone they've seen, of someone they've heard about, of someone they've known who was killed in the falls.
小时候，我们经常去瀑布，几乎每个周末，通常是在爷爷奶奶家吃周日晚餐之前。然而，我从未真正克服对瀑布的恐惧。尽管我那个夏天每天三次带领游客参观尼亚加拉，但我从未克服对它们的恐惧。那里的水流太急，落差太突然。你不能站在悬崖边缘——看着水滚滚而下，变幻万千却又始终如一——你不能站在那里而不让这个念头闪过脑海：跳下去该多容易，多平静啊。这种情况确实会发生。经常。每个住在这里的人都有一个故事，关于他们见过的人，关于他们听说过的人，关于他们认识的在瀑布中丧生的人。
Sometimes people will plan for a long time for a trip to the falls. They stand there watching the water for a while. Usually they'll remove their shoes, place their belongings, their personal effects inside their shoes, climb up over the railing and jump. I've seen it happen once. It was terrible. A young woman.
有时人们会为去瀑布旅行筹划很长时间。他们站在那里看一会儿水。通常他们会脱掉鞋子，把个人物品放在鞋里，爬过栏杆跳下去。我见过一次。太可怕了。一个年轻女子。
I was at Table Rock guiding a tour. There was commotion as the would-be be rescuers ran past us. There were people on the observation deck calling out to the people on the Maid of the Mist boat trip who were taking photos of the majestic cataract, waving to the people 158 feet above, people who had seen her jump and were now trying to get the tourists aboard the boat to help the woman who was now being tossed about in the swirling waters. Her body was sucked behind the curtain of water. Disappeared. I don't know if they ever found her body. Sometimes they don't.
我在桌岩（Table Rock）带团。当那些想要救援的人跑过我们身边时，引起了一阵骚乱。观景台上有人对着那些乘坐“雾中少女号”游船的人大喊，那些游客正在拍摄宏伟的瀑布，向158英尺上方的人们挥手，他们看到了她跳下去，现在正试图让船上的游客帮助那个在漩涡中翻腾的女人。她的身体被吸进了水幕后面。消失了。我不知道他们是否找到了她的遗体。有时他们找不到。
They pay people to go down to the lower river and retrieve the bodies they do find. $100 a body.
他们花钱请人下到下游去打捞他们发现的遗体。每具遗体100美元。
I think it started back in my grandfather's day. He did a lot of hunting and a lot of fishing. Them days they used to hunt below the falls. And being he was around the river all the time, any time they had someone jump over the falls, commit suicide or someone drowned accidentally, or someone would fall over the cliff, they'd get my grandfather to go down and recover the bodies or if the person was injured to find them and get the help to bring them up. Well, then from there, it went to my dad.
我想这是从我祖父那一代开始的。他经常打猎和钓鱼。那些日子，他们过去常在瀑布下方打猎。因为他一直在这条河边，每当有人跳下瀑布、自杀或有人意外溺水，或者有人从悬崖上掉下来时，他们就会叫我祖父下去打捞遗体，或者如果有人受伤，就把他们找出来，带他们上来。好吧，后来，这传给了我爸爸。
Now, when I was eight or nine years old, I used to go down with my dad when he pulled bodies out. I'd just stand back and watch. He did the same to all my brothers. And I got three boys and a daughter. And all my boys used to go down with me to retrieve the bodies too, help us carry them up and everything.
现在，当我八九岁的时候，我常跟着爸爸去打捞遗体。我就站在后面看。他对我的所有兄弟也都这样做。我有三个儿子和一个女儿。我所有的儿子也都跟着我下去打捞遗体，帮我们把他们抬上来等等。
Wes Hill collects the dead bodies of people who go over the falls. A warning-- some of his descriptions may be a little graphic for some listeners.
韦斯·希尔（Wes Hill）专门负责打捞那些坠入瀑布的人的遗体。警告一下——他的一些描述对某些听众来说可能有些生动。
After you see one or two or three, you get used to it. It's just like looking at a dead animal really, because 90% of these people committed suicide. And it wasn't accidental. They wanted to be there, so why feel sorry for them? And it gets so after you've taken out a hundred or so, then it's just like somebody repairing a car. It's the same thing over and over again. And I've taken around 400 bodies out of the river.
在你见过一两次或三次之后，你就习惯了。这真的就像看一只死动物，因为90%的人都是自杀。这不是意外。他们想去那里，所以为什么要为他们感到难过呢？捞过一百来个之后，这就变得像修理汽车一样。一次又一次，都是一样。我从河里捞出过大约400具遗体。
One time, it was in the afternoon. I was going to collect my paycheck. And it was too early to get my paycheck. I had to wait a couple hours. My wife was with me, so I said, let's drive down to the Maid of the Mist, and I'll go look around the driftwood, see what's floating in there. Because I got all kinds of fish and tackle and boat parts and everything out of the driftwood years ago. So as I parked car in the parking lot of the Maid of the Mist, I could see something pink going around the point just below the Maid of the Mist docks. There's a point of a rock that sticks out. I told my wife, that looked like someone's back or something.
有一次，是在下午。我要去领工资。当时太早了，还领不了。我得等几个小时。我妻子和我在一起，我说，我们开车去“雾中少女号”那边吧，我去看看流木，看看有什么漂在那儿。因为多年前我从流木里捞到过各种各样的鱼、渔具、船部件等等。当我把车停在“雾中少女号”停车场时，我看到“雾中少女号”码头下方有什么粉红色的东西绕过海角。那里有一块突出的岩石。我告诉妻子，那看起来像某个人的背部之类的东西。
So I walked in behind one of the docks, and I got a pike pole. It's a logger's pole they have the pull out driftwood. I got that, and I walked around the bay and went in behind this big rock. And here's an old woman laying there in the water. So I grabbed her by the arm and pulled her up on shore. Her body was still warm and everything, but her back was all smashed. She was dead. Apparently somebody in Montreal went to visit his mother and father. And he went in the house. And there's a suicide note on the table saying that one didn't want to live without the other. And being they're up in their 70s, they figure, one could die any time. So they said they're going over Niagara Falls and jump together. And they did. We got her body that day, and I got the man's body about a week later.
所以我走到码头后面，拿了一根钩杆。这是伐木工用来拉流木的杆子。我拿上它，绕过海湾，走到这块大石头后面。结果是一位老妇人躺在水里。所以我抓住她的胳膊把她拉上岸。她的身体还是暖的，但背部都碎了。她死了。显然，蒙特利尔有人去拜访他的父母。他走进屋子，桌上有张遗书，说一个人不想在没有另一个人陪伴的情况下活着。由于他们已经70多岁了，他们认为，一个人随时可能死去。所以他们说他们要一起跳下尼亚加拉大瀑布。他们真的这么做了。那天我们捞到了她的遗体，大约一周后我捞到了那个男人的。
I got a 18-year-old girl out of the river. She got pregnant, and her boyfriend said he'd marry her. And then he didn't, and she accidentally caught him with another girl. And she jumped over the falls. And of course, with the pressure on the body, when I went to pull her body out, the baby was halfway out. That is sickening.
我从河里捞出了一个18岁的女孩。她怀孕了，男朋友说会娶她。但后来他没有，而且她意外发现他和另一个女孩在一起。于是她跳下了瀑布。当然，由于身体承受的压力，当我把她的尸体捞出来时，婴儿已经掉出一半了。太令人作呕了。
Back in 1950, my brother, Red, decided he was going to try to go over the falls in a barrel. And he figured he needed something light, that if it hit any rocks, it would bounce so he wouldn't get hurt. So he got these big truck inner tubes, and he had them all put together with nylon webbing and everything, and a large net over the whole thing. The ends were closed with smaller inner tubes.
1950年，我的兄弟瑞德（Red）决定尝试用木桶翻越瀑布。他认为他需要一些轻便的东西，如果撞到岩石，它会反弹，这样他就不会受伤。所以他弄了这些大卡车内胎，用尼龙织带把它们全部绑在一起，外面还有一个大网。两端用较小的内胎封住。
And he figured if he went over in this thing made with inner tubes-- and he called it the Thing-- that he'd come out all right. So I told him, I'm not going to help you. And he said, why? I said, mainly because you weigh more than the barrel you're going over in. And I said, those inner tubes, when you go over the falls, it's going to hit the water and stop dead. And I said, you're going to shoot right through it, right out of it. No, no, he says, I'll be all right.
他认为如果他乘这个用内胎做的东西——他称之为“那个东西”（the Thing）——他就会安然无恙。所以我告诉他，我不会帮你。他说，为什么？我说，主要是因为你比你要翻越的木桶重。我说，那些内胎，当你冲下瀑布时，它会撞到水面并完全静止。我说，你会直接穿过它，被甩出来的。不，不，他说，我会没事的。
I seen him that morning when he left my house. I was with my mother. And I went down to the Maid of the Mist landing with my brothers and my mother, because they figured he'd come out all right and they wanted to be there to greet him. And I was standing on the dock of the Maid of the Mist when I seen this jumble of tubes come out. And I turned to my mother and said, Bill's dead. She said, how do you know? I said, look at the tubes. They're all smashed up. And the small boat from the Maid of the Mist pulled the tubes in. He wasn't in it. They got his body the next morning.
那天早上他离开我家时我见到了他。我和我母亲在一起。我和我的兄弟们还有母亲去了“雾中少女号”登陆点，因为他们觉得他会安然无恙，想去那里迎接他。我站在“雾中少女号”的码头上时，看到一堆内胎漂了出来。我转向我母亲说，比尔（Bill）死了。她说，你怎么知道？我说，看那些内胎。它们全碎了。“雾中少女号”的小船把内胎拖了过来。他不在里面。他们第二天早上捞到了他的遗体。
My mother had been fighting my father and us boys for years. Every time we'd go down to the whirlpool, take a body out or rescue somebody, she'd say, you're going to get in trouble. Stay home. She'd worry about us all the time we were gone. She always did that. When my brother said he was going over the falls, two of the neighbors said, why don't you try to stop him? She says, ain't no sense in talking to my family. She says, see? I can't talk him out of it. She tried, but we're all bullheaded.
我母亲多年来一直在和我父亲以及我们兄弟抗争。每次我们去漩涡处打捞尸体或救援某人时，她都会说，你们会惹上麻烦的。待在家里。她总是担心我们。她一直都这样。当我兄弟说他要翻越瀑布时，两个邻居说，为什么不阻止他？她说，和我家人谈没用。她说，看见没？我说服不了他。她尽力了，但我们都很倔。
Did she hate the falls or did she--
她恨瀑布，还是——
She hated it. She really hated it. My other brother Norman, he worked on the Maid of the Mist for years, and when they started the hydro project, he went to work in the hydro. And he was down working in the tunnels, and a rock came down one of the shafts and hit him on the head and killed him. So actually, he was killed working along the river too.
她恨它。她真的很恨它。我的另一个兄弟诺曼（Norman）在“雾中少女号”工作多年，当他们开始水利工程时，他去水利局工作了。他在隧道里工作时，一块岩石从竖井掉下来打中了他的头，杀了他。所以实际上，他也是在河边工作时丧生的。
There's a legend for retelling by tour guides. I would retell this legend at the base of the Bridal Veil Falls during the Cave of the Winds trip part of my tour. This is a legend.
有一个导游常讲的传说。我会在旅游团参观“风之洞”（Cave of the Winds）部分时，在面纱瀑布（Bridal Veil Falls）底部重述这个传说。这是一个传说。
Every year the Indians who lived at the falls would, in the autumn, choose a maid to be sacrificed at Niagara to appease the angry god who lived in the waterfall, to ensure safe passage through long, cold, dark winter months. Now, it happened one year that the kind chief's only lovely daughter was selected as the maid of sacrifice. The chief loved his daughter very much. And though it broke his heart, he went through with the preparations. When the fateful day arrived, the canoe, beautifully painted and laden with garlands of flowers and cornucopias of nature's bounty was carried to the village with his lovely only daughter inside. It was set into the river, and she drifted away, silently, nobly to her destiny.
每年秋天，住在瀑布的印第安人会选出一名少女作为祭品投下尼亚加拉，以安抚住在瀑布里的愤怒的神，确保平安度过漫长、寒冷、黑暗的冬日。现在，有一年，善良酋长唯一可爱的女儿被选为祭品少女。酋长非常爱他的女儿。虽然这让他心碎，但他还是完成了准备工作。当那决定性的一天到来时，装饰精美、装满花环和象征自然馈赠的丰饶角的小船带着他唯一可爱的女儿被抬到了村子里。它被放入河中，她静静地、高贵地漂向了她的命运。
When she hit the first rapids above the falls, she let out a small cry of terror, and her father, overcome by heartwrenching grief, jumped into his own canoe in hopes of rescuing her. As her canoe tossed and turned in the rapids, she called out again and again. The chief paddled faster, but alas, he was too late. With a final cry, she passed over the brink and was lost. Her father paddled with speed to the edge, and he too disappeared. It is said that the roar that you hear at the falls is the father crying out in anger, and the mist you feel raining down are her tears.
当她到达瀑布上方的第一个激流时，她发出一声小小的尖叫，她的父亲悲痛欲绝，跳进自己的独木舟，希望能救她。当她的船在激流中颠簸翻转时，她一次又一次地呼救。酋长划得更快，但唉，他太晚了。伴随着最后一声呼喊，她翻过悬崖边缘消失了。她的父亲拼命划向边缘，他也消失了。据说，你在瀑布听到的轰鸣声是父亲愤怒的呼喊，而你感到像雨一样落下的雾气则是她的泪水。
I would retell this legend three times a day every day to Australian and German tourists, to visitors from Tokyo and Bombay, to smiling blond-haired, straight-toothed families from Nebraska. They would smile and nod. Smile and nod. And then, simply because I could not help myself, I would tell them that the whole thing was a fabrication. Not true at all.
我每天会三次重述这个传说，讲给澳大利亚和德国游客听，讲给来自东京和孟买的游客，讲给来自内布拉斯加州带着微笑、牙齿整齐的金发家庭听。他们会微笑点头。微笑点头。然后，仅仅因为我无法控制自己，我会告诉他们这一切都是编造的。一点都不真实。
The visitors, whether from Missouri or Melbourne, would lower their cameras, squinting at me, slack-jawed, like they were woken from a dream. I'd tell them that the aboriginal people who lived here never, ever engaged in human sacrifice of any kind, that really, what was in a way amazing about this story was that it survived for so long from the time of the very earliest tour guides in the area, from the 1820s when Niagara was only just starting up.
游客们，无论是来自密苏里州还是墨尔本，都会放下相机，眯着眼睛看着我，目瞪口呆，就像从梦中醒来一样。我会告诉他们，住在这里的原住民从来没有任何形式的人祭，真正令人惊讶的是，这个故事从1820年代尼亚加拉刚开始开发时起，竟然能在最早的导游口中流传这么久。
What I didn't tell them was that I would, as a kid, attend the Maid of the Mist parade every summer. It came right down main street in Niagara Falls. And at the end of the parade every year, after the Shriners, the Knights of Columbus, high school bands and waving dignitaries, the most elaborate float would appear-- a re-creation of the Maid of the Mist legend, usually with a pretty young woman from the reservation nearby. There she'd be in her chicken wire and crepe paper canoe, poised on the very brink of the paper mache cataract, smiling, waving, throwing wooden nickels.
我没告诉他们的是，我小时候每年夏天都会参加“雾中少女号”游行。它就沿着尼亚加拉瀑布的主街开过。每年游行结束时，在圣地兄弟会（Shriners）、哥伦布骑士会（Knights of Columbus）、高中乐队和挥手的政要之后，最精致的花车就会出现——那是“雾中少女号”传说的再现，通常由附近保留地的一位漂亮年轻女子扮演。她会坐在用鸡肉网和绉纸糊成的独木舟里，立在纸糊的瀑布边缘，微笑、挥手，抛撒木制硬币。
I met a man in a bar who told me a story about the city of Niagara Falls, which is the story I think of whenever I'm trying to explain Niagara to myself. He told me that the mayor of the city gets two things-- a $30,000 salary and a license plate for his car. The license plate reads NF number one-- Niagara Falls number one.
我在一家酒吧认识了一个人，他告诉我一个关于尼亚加拉瀑布城的故事，每当我试图向自己解释尼亚加拉时，我都会想到这个故事。他告诉我，市长会得到两样东西——3万美元的薪水和一块汽车牌照。车牌上写着“NF 1”——尼亚加拉瀑布第一。
A couple years ago, there was a mayor in Niagara who got voted out of office, but was so mad about being ousted that he refused to give the license plate to the new mayor. They argued back and forth and back and forth, the new mayor insisting the old mayor give the plate up, the old mayor refusing. Finally, said the man in the a bar, the new mayor came up with a plan. He hired some men to steal the plate off the car of the old mayor. This, I should say, is unlikely. The new mayor was a policeman for 31 years, and he absolutely denied taking the plate. But the man in the bar said that he and many of his friends didn't believe the mayor. He said, this is the kind of town Niagara is. It's the kind of town where the new mayor steals the license plate off the old mayor's car.
几年前，尼亚加拉的一位市长在选举中落败，但他对被赶下台感到非常愤怒，拒绝把车牌交给新市长。他们争来争去，新市长坚持要老市长交出车牌，老市长拒绝。最后，酒吧里的那个人说，新市长想出了一个计划。他雇了一些人把车牌从老市长的车上偷走。我应该说，这不太可能。新市长当过31年警察，他绝对否认拿过车牌。但酒吧里那个人说，他和他的许多朋友都不相信市长。他说，这就是尼亚加拉这样的城镇。这就是那种新市长会从老市长车上偷车牌的城镇。
Don Glynn is a newspaper man who's worked at the Niagara Gazette for 37 years, not including his time as a paper boy. He takes me on a tour of the city. We drive through downtown Niagara. There's not much driving to do. It's mostly a grid of empty lots. So we circle the same streets over and over, past the convention center, past the old Niagara Hotel, past the Wintergarden and the Rainbow Mall, past the convention center, past the old Niagara Hotel.
唐·格林（Don Glynn）是一位报人，在《尼亚加拉公报》工作了37年，还不算他当送报员的时间。他带我参观这座城市。我们开车穿过尼亚加拉市中心。没什么可看的。大部分是一个个空地的网格。所以我们一遍又一遍地绕着同样的街道，经过会议中心，经过旧尼亚加拉酒店，经过冬季花园和彩虹购物中心，经过会议中心，经过旧尼亚加拉酒店。
You see this big building here, the flashcube, we call it. That's the Occidental Chemical center. There's very little occupancy in there anymore because, well, Occidental has moved out for the most part. And the largest tenant in that nine story building-- this says something about the city of Niagara Falls-- the largest tenant is the Small Business Disaster Assistance office.
你看这边的大楼，我们称之为闪光立方体。那是西方化学中心（Occidental Chemical center）。那里几乎没什么人入驻了，因为，嗯，西方化学公司大部分都搬走了。而在那座九层大楼里，最大的租户——这说明了尼亚加拉瀑布城的一些情况——最大的租户是小型企业灾害援助办公室。
All these places on both sides of the street for two or three blocks are just bars. And a lot of them are in Chapter 11. In fact, I often thought it would be neat to open a bar and just call it Chapter 11. It'd probably be packed with all the people that can't pay their bills.
街道两旁两三个街区的所有这些地方都是酒吧。很多都处于第11章破产保护状态。事实上，我常想如果开一家酒吧，直接叫“第11章”会很酷。里面可能挤满了那些还不起账单的人。
Niagara was an industrial boomtown from the '20s through the early '50s, but in the late '50s and '60s, the electrochemical companies which lined the river found cheap power, nonunion labor, and lower taxes in other states. They left, and people left with them. Then in the late '60s and early '70s, things got so bad that Niagara elected a flamboyant mayor with a plan.
从20年代到50年代初，尼亚加拉曾是一个工业繁荣的城镇，但在50年代末和60年代，河边的电化学公司在其他州找到了廉价电力、非工会劳动力和较低的税收。它们离开了，人们也随之离开。后来在60年代末和70年代初，情况变得如此糟糕，以至于尼亚加拉选出了一位浮夸的市长，并提出了一个计划。
The mayor was E. Dent Lackey, and the plan was urban renewal. It was a simple plan which had three parts. Part one, the city would buy up all the property on the 82 acres of land which constituted Niagara's downtown area. Part two, the city would tear down all the property on the 82 acres of land which it had bought. And part three, developers from across America would flock to buy the empty lots, and they would build a new city.
这位市长是E.登特·莱基（E. Dent Lackey），计划就是城市更新。这是一个简单的计划，分为三个部分。第一部分，城市将买下构成尼亚加拉市中心的82英亩土地上的所有房产。第二部分，城市将拆除买下的82英亩土地上的所有房产。第三部分，来自全美各地的开发商将蜂拥而至购买空地，他们将建造一座新城市。
This plan is part of the reason it doesn't take very long to go on a driving tour of Niagara Falls. They only made it through parts one and two.
这个计划是为什么在尼亚加拉瀑布城开车游览不需要太长时间的原因之一。他们只完成了第一和第二部分。
Everything was just kind of like leveled, and they thought that all these developers would come in and rebuild. And that didn't happen, because the developers weren't standing in line like this mayor thought they would be. They just didn't want to come here, and they didn't want to invest.
一切都被推平了，他们以为所有的开发商都会来重建。但这并没有发生，因为开发商并没有像这位市长想象的那样排队。他们只是不想来这里，也不想投资。
So it was this one administration that just kind of leveled the city.
所以正是这届政府把这座城市给推平了。
I thought he had a lot to do with it, Mayor E. Dent Lackey, for whom the plaza is named, by the way. You tear down a city and they name a plaza for you.
我觉得他与此有很大关系，E.登特·莱基市长，顺便说一句，广场就是以他的名字命名的。你拆毁了一座城市，他们却用你的名字命名一个广场。
Don turns a corner and drives us past the Lackey Plaza, a large concrete square with a shallow white wall around it in front of Niagara's convention center. He points to the corner of the wall, where there's a smooth bronze plate.
唐转过一个弯，开车经过莱基广场（Lackey Plaza），这是一个巨大的混凝土广场，前面有浅白色的墙，就在尼亚加拉会议中心前面。他指着墙的角落，那里有一块光滑的铜牌。
See that marker there on the end there? See that little plate there? It looks like just an empty space.
看到那个尽头的标志了吗？看到那个小牌子了吗？看起来就像是一块空地。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
Somebody stole the plaque. That's the Lackey Plaza, and that was the only proof that that was the Lackey Plaza, and someone stole it. It's been gone for like half a dozen years, the Lackey Plaza plaque. Does that tell you something about the city? Isn't that pathetic? I mean somebody felt that strongly about it that they removed the plaque. But that tells you something.
有人把牌子偷了。那是莱基广场，那是那是莱基广场的唯一证明，结果有人把它偷了。莱基广场的牌子已经丢了大概六七年了。这能说明这座城市的情况吗？这不悲哀吗？我是说有人对它感觉如此强烈，以至于把牌子给拆了。但这确实说明了什么。
We drive up the street a ways, past two enormous parking complexes a couple of blocks from the falls. They are pristine structures, four-story garages which take up two entire city blocks and dwarf everything around them.
我们沿着街道开了一段路，经过了距离瀑布几个街区的两个巨大的停车大楼。它们是原始的建筑，四层的车库占据了整整两个城市街区，使周围的一切都显得渺小。
We've got these ramp garages, and they've never really been filled. They've never been used, and they're free. You notice that? Yeah, because it was foolish to try to charge. Finally they put a fee on this one here, but that's only because they're trying to take advantage of the people that work in the office building across the street. But the one closest to the falls is free. You can walk in there, and all the levels are free. It doesn't cost anything. And yet all the booths are in place there and the electronic system and the cars. They spent a lot of money on just setting up the mechanisms, and they don't use it.
我们有这些坡道车库，它们从来没有真正满过。它们从来没被使用过，而且是免费的。你注意到了吗？是的，因为试图收费是愚蠢的。最后他们在这一个上设了费，但这只是因为他们想利用在街对面办公大楼工作的人。但最靠近瀑布的那一个是免费的。你可以走进去，所有的楼层都是免费的。什么都不花。然而所有的收费亭都在那里，还有电子系统和车辆。他们花了很多钱来设置这些机构，结果却不用。
You got to remember that this is probably the capital of pipe dreams. I don't know why that is. You could go over to Navy Island, which is close by. It's around five miles away. That was one of the sites suggested once for the home of the United Nations. I mean, that's big thinking and big planning, right? Of course it never happened because the Rockefellers donated the land in New York. But they actually thought they could get the United Nations here.
你得记住，这可能是空想的首都。我不知道为什么会这样。你可以去附近的海军岛（Navy Island）。离这里大约五英里。那里曾是建议作为联合国总部的地点之一。我是说，那是大思考和大规划，对吧？当然这从未实现，因为洛克菲勒家族捐赠了纽约的土地。但他们真的认为他们能把联合国弄到这里来。
More than half of Niagara's population has left since the '50s. With industry gone, Don tells me about 2/3 of the population of Niagara Falls is on some form of public aid, and almost 60% of its population is elderly.
自50年代以来，尼亚加拉超过一半的人口已经离开。随着工业的消失，唐告诉我，尼亚加拉瀑布城大约三分之二的人口依靠某种形式的公共援助，近60%的人口是老年人。
Young people do not stay here. They move out.
年轻人不会留在这里。他们搬走了。
So in another, let's say, 20 years, you're going to have an entire city full of 80-year-olds. This is going to be like a huge retirement village or senior citizen's village.
所以再过个20年，你将拥有一整座住满80岁老人的城市。这就像一个巨大的退休村或老年村。
Absolutely. No question. I think you're right. Young people just don't come in here and don't stay here.
绝对。毫无疑问。我想你是对的。年轻人就是不进来，也不留在这里。
And then, 25 years from now, it's going to be a ghost town, isn't it?
那么，25年后，这就会变成一座鬼城，不是吗？
Well, it has all the makings of that, yeah.
嗯，它具备了所有这些条件，是的。
Coming up, two weddings and a funeral, plus tape recordings made by someone inside a barrel as he went over the falls. Guess which Bon Jovi song he was listening to as he went over the brink. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，两场婚礼和一场葬礼，还有一个人在木桶里翻越瀑布时录下的磁带。猜猜他在翻越边缘时听的是邦乔维（Bon Jovi）的哪首歌。从PRI国际公共广播电台收听，节目继续，稍后回来。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of stories on that theme. Today's program, Niagara. Stories from documentary producer Alix Spiegel, who visited the falls, and from David Kodeski, who grew up there. In one sense, the story of Niagara Falls is the story of how we as Americans relate to nature. We revere it and romanticize it on the one hand, and we try to exploit on the other.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目是：尼亚加拉。故事来自纪录片制片人爱丽丝·斯皮格尔（她参观了瀑布），以及在那里长大的大卫·科德斯基。从某种意义上说，尼亚加拉大瀑布的故事就是我们作为美国人如何看待自然的故事。一方面，我们崇敬它，浪漫化它；另一方面，我们试图开发它。
It's no accident that one of our country's most famous ecological disasters, Love Canal, where so many toxic chemicals were dumped that residents had to be evacuated, is just a few minutes' drive from the falls. Those chemicals were there because so many factories grew up near the falls, near the cheap hydroelectric power provided by the falls. And that's where our story continues.
我们国家最著名的生态灾难之一——爱河（Love Canal）——绝非偶然，那里倾倒了太多有毒化学物质，导致居民不得不疏散，距离瀑布只有几分钟的车程。这些化学物质之所以存在，是因为太多的工厂在瀑布附近兴起，靠近瀑布提供的廉价水电。我们的故事就在那里继续。
Cheap, plentiful hydroelectric power lured the electrochemical industries of the world to Niagara. My father worked 40 years or so for DuPont in the sodium facility there. My uncle Ray worked for Carborundum, my cousin Paul for Union Carbide, my cousin Carl for Goodyear Tire and Rubber, my uncle Matt for Occidental Chemical and Petroleum, formerly known as Hooker Chemical.
廉价且充足的水电吸引了世界各地的电化学工业来到尼亚加拉。我父亲在杜邦（DuPont）的钠工厂工作了40年左右。我叔叔雷（Ray）在金刚砂（Carborundum）工作，表弟保罗在联合碳化物（Union Carbide），表弟卡尔在固特异轮胎橡胶（Goodyear Tire and Rubber），叔叔马特在西方化学和石油（Occidental Chemical and Petroleum，前身为胡克化学 Hooker Chemical）。
The factories line the Niagara River not far from the falls themselves. When I was driving tours that summer, we were instructed to direct the attention of our guests toward the river to point out the wideness of the river, to point out the relative calmness of the water. We were instructed to keep the attention toward the river and away from the chemical factories belching yellow and white smoke. None of this would appear in the official tour guide training manuals, of course, but the veteran guides who trained us reminded us that we were working for tips. And who would tip a tour guide who pointed out a ravaged and polluted landscape?
工厂排列在尼亚加拉河沿岸，距离瀑布本身不远。那个夏天当我开车带团时，我们被指示引导客人的注意力看向河流，指出河流的宽阔，指出水流的相对平静。我们被指示保持注意力看向河流，远离喷出黄色和白色烟雾的化工厂。当然，这些内容不会出现在正式的导游培训手册中，但培训我们的老导游提醒我们，我们是靠小费工作的。而且，谁会给指出一片荒芜和污染景观的导游小费呢？
Someone whose attention had drifted to the east might ask, what are those factories? And we were then instructed to explain how during the war effort these plants had supplied the armed services to aid in beating the Axis powers and those nylons GIs were plying Euro cuties with were made right here in Niagara Falls.
注意力漂移到东边的人可能会问，那些工厂是什么？我们当时被指示解释说，在战争期间，这些工厂为武装部队提供了物资，以帮助击败轴心国势力，而大兵们用来讨好欧洲美女的尼龙制品正是这里在尼亚加拉大瀑布制造的。
The summer I turned 17, there was a great deal of family talk about which plant I should work for, just for the summer, see if I like it. The money's good. The money is very good. But I did not want to work in any one of the factories under any circumstances. They seemed deadly. I knew that my grandfather retired early because of his failing health. He died of pancreatic cancer in 1966.
我17岁那年的夏天，家里有很多关于我应该为哪家工厂工作的谈论，只是为了过暑假，看看我是否喜欢。工资不错。工资非常高。但我无论如何都不想在任何一家工厂工作。它们看起来很致命。我知道我的祖父因为健康状况不佳提前退休了。他于1966年死于胰腺癌。
My grandfather was a chemical operator. He ran what they called caustic, caustic and chlorine. They make drain cleaner out of it, detergents, soap too. They use it to purify water. My relatives say dioxin was in the air there. They say that when they made caustic, the vapor would go up and it would turn into caustic dust. They say it was everywhere, even in the place where they ate. They say you could write your name in the dust on the table. You'd leave your coffee cup on the table, and there'd be a mark.
我祖父是一名化学操作工。他经营他们所谓的烧碱，苛性钠和氯。他们用它制造下水道清洁剂、洗涤剂，还有肥皂。他们用它来净化水。我的亲戚们说空气中有二恶英。他们说，当他们制造烧碱时，蒸汽上升，会变成烧碱灰尘。他们说到处都是，甚至在他们吃饭的地方。他们说你可以把名字写在桌子的灰尘上。你会把咖啡杯留在桌子上，就会留下一个印记。
I spent a lot of time sitting on the front porch of my parents' house staring at the factories on the horizon-- towers, ironworks, smokestacks. You could also see the mist of the falls from there, but you couldn't be sure if it was the mist you were seeing or the smoke from the factories. Near my parents' house, kids would play on the sites of abandoned factories and dump sites. They called them the whites because everything there was thick with white ash. It's hard to say what this did to people. If you look at the studies, Niagara's cancer rate is higher than other areas, but just a little.
我花了很多时间坐在父母房子的前廊上，盯着地平线上的工厂——塔楼、铁工厂、烟囱。从那里也能看到瀑布的雾气，但你无法确定你看到的是雾气还是工厂的烟雾。在我父母家附近，孩子们常在废弃工厂和垃圾堆的地点玩耍。他们称之为“白色地带”，因为那里到处都是厚厚的白色灰尘。很难说这对人们造成了什么影响。如果你看研究报告，尼亚加拉的癌症率确实比其他地区高，但只高出一点点。
He went in and out of the hospital for months. One night when Tom was home from the hospital, we were all watching a movie on television, Karen Black in Trilogy of Terror , the one where she gets chased around her apartment by that little Zuni fetish doll. And Tom had to go to the bathroom. And we helped him down the hall and into the bathroom, and he had a seizure. He went limp. He passed out on the bathroom floor, and his eyes rolled back into his head. We all started to cry.
他在医院进进出出好几个月。一天晚上，当汤姆（Tom）从医院回家时，我们都在看电视上的电影，《三部惊魂》（Trilogy of Terror），凯伦·布莱克（Karen Black）在那部电影里被那个小祖尼（Zuni）神像娃娃在公寓里追赶。汤姆得去洗手间。我们帮他沿着大厅走进洗手间，他癫痫发作了。他全身瘫软。他在洗手间地板上昏了过去，眼睛向后翻。我们都开始哭。
That summer, Tom was given radiation therapy, cobalt treatments. We had to watch him. We had to take care of him. Sharon was taking care of him one afternoon, and they were playing with some toy soldiers in the yard. Sharon believes that Tom knew that he was dying. He was killing the already fallen soldiers, shooting them over and over. And Sharon said, why are you killing them like that? Well, he said, well, they won't suffer like that.
那个夏天，汤姆接受了放射治疗，钴治疗。我们必须看着他。我们必须照顾他。一天下午，莎伦（Sharon）在照顾他，他们在院子里玩一些玩具士兵。莎伦相信汤姆知道他快死了。他杀死了那些已经倒下的士兵，一遍又一遍地射击他们。莎伦说，你为什么要那样杀他们？好吧，他说，好吧，他们那样就不会受苦了。
Death and love-- that's what Niagara represents-- the nexus of death and love. Suicides on the one hand, honeymoons on the other. When I told a friend I was going to Niagara Falls, he asked me if I was getting married. Four different people asked me that question. I told them all I had no immediate plans. Then I called 1-800-785-L-O-V-E, the Niagara wedding chapel at the Radisson Hotel in Niagara Falls, New York.
死亡与爱情——这就是尼亚加拉所代表的——死亡与爱情的交汇点。一方面是自杀，另一方面是蜜月。当我告诉一个朋友我要去尼亚加拉瀑布时，他问我是不是要去结婚。四个不同的人问了我这个问题。我告诉他们我没有任何直接计划。然后我拨打了1-800-785-L-O-V-E，位于纽约尼亚加拉瀑布雷迪森酒店（Radisson Hotel）的尼亚加拉婚礼教堂。
The Niagara wedding chapel offers what they call a full-service wedding, which means that in addition to a ceremony with flowers, preacher, complimentary bottle of champagne, license, and wedding video, I'm entitled to a day of beauty at the hair salon next door and a discount on a room for my wedding night at the Radisson. Niagara, I was told, is the honeymoon capital of the world. The Niagara wedding chapel performs over 2,000 weddings annually.
尼亚加拉婚礼教堂提供他们所谓的全方位服务婚礼，这意味着除了包含鲜花、牧师、赠送的一瓶香槟、结婚证和婚礼录像的仪式外，我还有权在隔壁的美发沙龙度过美丽的一天，并在雷迪森酒店享受婚宴之夜的房费折扣。我被告知，尼亚加拉是世界蜜月之都。尼亚加拉婚礼教堂每年举行超过2,000场婚礼。
At the end of our conversation, the man on the phone, who identified himself as the owner's brother, suggested that he and I get married. He told me he was single and I had a nice voice. I actually have his proposal in my notes of our conversation. There it is. Right under the information about the 24-hour waiting period, I wrote with a blue ballpoint pen, "Will marry me."
谈话结束时，电话那头的男人，他自称是店主的兄弟，建议我和他结婚。他告诉我他是单身，而且我的声音很好听。我确实在对话记录中记下了他的求婚。就在那里。在关于24小时等待期的信息下面，我用蓝色圆珠笔写道：“会嫁给我。”
It's Catherine and A.J.'s first time, which is a little unusual for the Niagara wedding chapel. Most of their market is second marriages. Catherine and A.J. have driven to Niagara from Pittsburgh with 30 of their friends and family, and are now waiting together with their maid of honor in the welcome area outside the chapel. They all look happy and nervous. They're laughing and joking, talking about the kinds of things you talk about right before you get married.
这是凯瑟琳（Catherine）和A.J.第一次，这在尼亚加拉婚礼教堂有点不寻常。他们大部分的市场是再婚。凯瑟琳和A.J.带着30个朋友和家人开车从匹兹堡来到尼亚加拉，现在正和伴娘一起在教堂外的欢迎区等待。他们看起来都很开心和紧张。他们欢声笑语，谈论着结婚前会谈论的事情。
A.J., you still have time to back out.
A.J.，你还有时间退出。
No.
不。
He's calmer than me.
他比我冷静。
I know. He's so calm. That's cool.
我知道。他太冷静了。这很酷。
I should have gone to the bathroom.
我应该去趟洗手间的。
Chris, the owner and manager of the Niagara chapel, comes in to tell Catherine and A.J. that even though two of their guests haven't arrived, the wedding must start. He's got a 4:30. He can't wait anymore. Everyone hurries to their places while Chris makes a brief announcement to their guests. They're allowed to take pictures, but everyone must remain in their seats until the end of the ceremony. I barely have time to wonder why this last instruction is necessary before--
尼亚加拉教堂的所有者兼经理克里斯（Chris）进来告诉凯瑟琳和A.J.，尽管有两位客人还没到，婚礼必须开始了。他4:30还有一场。他不能再等了。每个人都匆忙就位，克里斯对客人作了简短的说明。他们可以拍照，但每个人必须在仪式结束前保持就座。在我想知道为什么最后一条指示是必要之前——
[MUSIC - "BRIDAL CHORUS" BY RICHARD WAGNER]
[音乐——理查德·瓦格纳的《婚礼进行曲》]
Catherine starts crying as soon as she enters the chapel. She cries her way to the altar, cries as she takes her beside A.J., cries as the justice reads through the opening of the ceremony, cries more when the justice asks her if she'll love her husband through sickness and through health. The bareness of her emotion infects everyone in the room.
凯瑟琳一走进教堂就开始哭。她一路哭到祭坛前，并在A.J.身边站定时继续哭，当法官读完仪式开场白时也在哭，当法官问她是否会在疾病和健康中爱她的丈夫时，哭得更厉害了。她情感的赤裸感染了房间里的每一个人。
I see three people in the front row hunch their shoulders and bring their hands to their faces, then the man in the second row next to the wall, then the woman sitting next to him. It jumps the 12-year-old boy sitting next to her and moves to the third row, then the fourth. Now I am crying. We are all in the room crying. Everyone happy and flushed and sure that everything, everywhere is going to be OK after all.
我看到第一排的三个人蜷缩起肩膀，把手捂在脸上，然后是靠墙第二排的男人，然后是坐在他旁边的女人。它感染了坐在她旁边的12岁男孩，传到了第三排，然后是第四排。现在我也在哭。我们房间里所有人都哭了。每个人都快乐而面红耳赤，确信一切，到处都在某种程度上会好起来。
And then, six minutes and 47 seconds after it begins, it's finished. A.J. and Catherine are now husband and wife.
然后，在仪式开始六分47秒后，结束了。A.J.和凯瑟琳现在是夫妻了。
Ladies and gentlemen, it is my great pleasure to introduce to you Mr. and Mrs. [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
女士们，先生们，我非常高兴向大家介绍[听不清]先生和夫人。
[CHEERS]
[欢呼声]
In another 10 minutes they're gone. All evidence of the couple is removed, and the only sound in the chapel is the hum of fluorescent lights. Chris pops in a new video for the next couple and resets the video machine. He sets out a new bouquet and checks to see if the bride's dressing room is clean. Then his 4:30 arrives, Rod and Lori, just the two of them. No friends. No family. Lori goes to the bride's dressing room to check her makeup, and I try to talk to Rod. This is not an easy thing to do.
再过10分钟他们就走了。所有关于这对新人的证据都被移除了，教堂里唯一的声音是荧光灯的嗡嗡声。克里斯为下一对新人放入一个新的录像带，并重置了视频机。他摆上一束新花，检查新娘更衣室是否干净。然后他4:30的客人到了，罗德（Rod）和洛里（Lori），只有他们两个。没有朋友。没有家人。洛里去新娘更衣室检查妆容，我试图和罗德谈话。这可不容易。
Where are you coming from?
你们从哪儿来？
New Jersey.
新泽西。
Oh, all the way up from New Jersey?
哦，从新泽西一路过来吗？
Right.
是的。
What brought you up here?
是什么带你们来这里的？
Well, Lori.
嗯，洛里。
She wanted to come to the falls?
她想来瀑布吗？
Right.
是的。
Had you heard about it?
你听说过它吗？
Yeah, I think. You know.
是的，我想。你知道的。
He's very quiet.
他很安静。
He is.
确实。
Lori comes out, and she and Rod are introduced to the minister. There are handshakes and some uncomfortable laughter. Then--
洛里出来了，她和罗德被介绍给牧师。有一些握手和一些不自在的笑声。然后——
[MUSIC - "BRIDAL CHORUS" BY RICHARD WAGNER]
[音乐——理查德·瓦格纳的《婚礼进行曲》]
No one cries at this wedding. The two of them walk alone to the altar. The chapel is empty, just rows and rows of chairs. Rod and Lori stand stiffly as the preacher reads on and on. Rod seems perpetually awkward, not visibly happy at all. Lori isn't visibly happy either. As I've said, there's no one in the room, just a bunch of chairs and some video cameras. And it's hard not to wonder why they've chosen to engage in this exercise at all. It just seems so sad.
没人在这场婚礼上哭。他们两个独自走向祭坛。教堂空荡荡的，只有一排排椅子。罗德和洛里僵硬地站着，牧师一直在读。罗德看起来一直很别扭，一点也不显得快乐。洛里看起来也不快乐。正如我所说，房间里没有人，只有一堆椅子和一些录像机。不禁要问为什么他们选择参加这种活动。看起来太悲伤了。
I look around the little stage that serves as a wedding altar, where all day long it's a series of these dramas in 30-minute intervals, one couple after another, some happy, some not. Then eight minutes after it began, it's over. Rod and Lori are husband and wife. No one's there to applaud.
我环顾四周，作为婚礼祭坛的小舞台，整天都在上演这种每隔30分钟一场的戏码，一对接一对，有的开心，有的不开心。然后仪式开始八分钟后，就结束了。罗德和洛里是夫妻了。没有人在那里鼓掌。
Niagara, home of the two-tank honeymoon-- one tank up, one tank back. That's what Chris tells me. He hands me a card which says, Niagara, honeymoon capital of the world. But Niagara isn't the honeymoon capital of the world. It hasn't been for a long, long time. It held this title between the 1840s and the 1940s when the railroads made Niagara a cheap and easy weekend getaway for newlyweds in New York, Pennsylvania, Ohio, New Jersey, all up and down the east coast.
尼亚加拉，两箱油蜜月之乡——一箱去，一箱回。这就是克里斯告诉我的。他递给我一张卡片，上面写着：尼亚加拉，世界蜜月之都。但尼亚加拉并不是世界蜜月之都。已经很久很久不是了。它在1840年代到1940年代拥有这个称号，当时铁路使尼亚加拉成为纽约、宾夕法尼亚州、俄亥俄州、新泽西州以及整个东海岸新婚夫妇廉价且便捷的周末度假地。
But the railroad was discontinued decades ago, and affordable air travel makes destinations like Hawaii much more popular with newlyweds today. But the idea of Niagara as honeymoon capital remains in a hundred old movies and songs. And those movies and songs are a powerful force.
但几十年前铁路就停止服务了，负担得起的航空旅行使夏威夷等目的地在今天的新婚夫妇中更受欢迎。但尼亚加拉作为蜜月之都的想法仍然存在于数百部老电影和歌曲中。而这些电影和歌曲是一种强大的力量。
Chris tells me he gets calls from Florence Italy, London England, from Japan. In the office in the back of the chapel, there's an entire wall of pictures of happy couples who have been married by Chris. I look at the pictures. Chris gets ready for his 5 o'clock.
克里斯告诉我，他接到来自意大利佛罗伦萨、英国伦敦、日本的电话。在教堂后面的办公室里，整面墙上都是克里斯主持婚礼的幸福夫妻的照片。我看着照片。克里斯准备他5点的婚礼。
Here's another story we would tell as tour guides. This one happens to be true.
这是我们做导游时会讲的另一个故事。这个故事恰好是真的。
Annie Edson Taylor was a 73-year-old school teacher from Bay City, Michigan. She arrived in Niagara sometime in the summer of 1903. She was alone, some say an old maid. She was penniless. She was desperate. She'd made up her mind that she would be the first person to go over Niagara Falls in a barrel and live. She designed and had built a special barrel. She hired a manager, one Frank M. "Tussy" Russell. Russell announced to the world that the 73-year-old Taylor was a widow, 42. Taylor met the press saying, I might as well be dead as remain in my present condition. It will be fame and fortune or instant death.
安妮·埃德森·泰勒（Annie Edson Taylor）是一位来自密歇根州贝城的73岁教师。她于1903年夏天抵达尼亚加拉。她独自一人，有人说是老处女。她身无分文。她走投无路。她打定主意，要成为第一个乘木桶翻越尼亚加拉大瀑布并活下来的人。她设计并建造了一个特殊的木桶。她雇了一名经理，叫弗兰克·M·“塔西”·拉塞尔（Frank M. "Tussy" Russell）。拉塞尔向世界宣布，73岁的泰勒是一位寡妇，42岁。泰勒见到记者时说，与其保持现状不如死掉。要么名利双收，要么当场毙命。
At half past 1:00 on October 24, 1903, Annie Edson Taylor squeezed into her barrel. Cold water inside the barrel sloshed around her ankles. Annie could feel the pull of the river, the swiftness of the rapids. Her barrel banged and scraped against the rocks above the falls. Annie, deafened by the roar of the river, prayed aloud. The barrel neared the crest of the mighty Horseshoe and hung there at the lip, seemingly stuck, hanging over the boiling chasm. The crowd gasped, held its breath, and then she dropped into the cataclysm, into the chasm, into the roiling tempest below. She was pulled out of the barrel below the falls, dazed, bleeding, but very much alive. A cheer went up from the assembled crowd. The woman is alive!
1903年10月24日下午1:30，安妮·埃德森·泰勒挤进了她的木桶。木桶里的冷水在她脚踝周围晃动。安妮能感觉到河流的拉力，激流的迅猛。她的木桶在瀑布上方的岩石上撞击和刮擦。被河水的咆哮震聋的安妮大声祈祷。木桶靠近了强大马蹄瀑布的顶端，悬挂在边缘，似乎卡住了，悬在沸腾的深渊上方。人群倒吸一口冷气，屏住呼吸，然后她冲进了激流，冲进了深渊，冲进了下方翻滚的暴风雨中。她在瀑布下方被从木桶里拉了出来，神志不清，浑身是血，但还活着。聚集的人群中爆发出一阵欢呼。那个女人还活着！
While Annie recuperated in a Canadian hotel, Frank M. "Tussy" Russell disappeared with Annie's barrel. He made his fortune with it and a beautiful young woman posing as Annie, queen of the falls.
当安妮在加拿大一家酒店康复时，弗兰克·M·“塔西”·拉塞尔带着安妮的木桶消失了。他用它发了大财，并让一个美丽的年轻女子冒充瀑布女王安妮。
Annie had another barrel built, posed for photos with it, told and retold her story to tourists for pennies. She wrote her autobiography. She aged on the streets of Niagara, told tourists she was a widow, 52. She became scary, died alone, a lady of good breeding and refinement.
安妮又造了另一个木桶，和它拍照，向游客重述她的故事，一次赚几分钱。她写了自己的自传。她在尼亚加拉街头变老，告诉游客她是寡妇，52岁。她变得很可怕，孤独地死去，一位出身良好、有教养的女士。
This is a story of my hometown. The prevailing symbol of the town used to be the beautiful Indian Maid of the Mist, when really it ought to have been bad luck, down at the heels Annie Edson Taylor, a lady of good breeding and refinement who never got an even break.
这是我家乡的故事。这个城镇的主流象征曾经是美丽的印第安雾中少女，而实际上它本应该是运气不佳、落魄的安妮·埃德森·泰勒，一位出身良好、有教养却从未得到公平对待的女士。
You have to become one. I remember when the guys were working on my barrel, I used to stand back, stand aside and just psych into it. I used to do a lot of work on it myself. And that's the only thing keeping you from death. You become one. You actually acquire quite a relationship with a barrel, a piece of metal, that one will not understand unless they're there. That is saving their life. So you can imagine the psyching in and the unity that you have with this vessel.
你必须成为一体。我还记得当那些家伙在修我的木桶时，我常站远点，站在一边，让自己进入状态。我自己也做了很多工作。而这是让你远离死亡的唯一东西。你们合二为一。你真的与一个木桶——一件金属制品——建立了某种关系，除非亲身经历，否则别人是无法理解的。那是救命的东西。所以你可以想象那种心理建设和与这个容器建立的统一感。
Peter DeBernardi lives half a mile from the falls, so close that his windows sometimes rattle from the roar. One night in 1987, Peter was lying in bed listening to the falls, and it hit him. He would make history by going over the falls in a barrel built for two men, the first time ever two people would go over together.
彼得·德伯纳迪（Peter DeBernardi）住在离瀑布半英里远的地方，近到他的窗户有时会被咆哮声震得嘎嘎作响。1987年的一天晚上，彼得躺在床上听着瀑布的声音，他突然有个念头。他要通过乘一个两人木桶翻越瀑布来创造历史，这是有史以来第一次两人一起翻越。
He found a partner, a guy named Jeff, and together with a crew of men they built a 3,000 pound deluxe steel barrel with inner tubes inside to cushion their fall, two windows of bulletproof glass so they could see out as they went over, and a stereo system so they could listen to tunes. They also installed a recording system so they could document the whole experience on tape. It took them 19 months to build. And then, as Peter will tell you, there was the mental preparation.
他找到了一个搭档，一个叫杰夫（Jeff）的人，和一帮人一起建造了一个3,000磅重的豪华钢制木桶，里面有内胎来缓冲下落，两个防弹玻璃窗以便他们在冲下去时能向外看，还有一个音响系统以便他们能听曲子。他们还安装了一个录音系统，以便能把整个经历记录在磁带上。他们花了19个月才造好。然后，正如彼得会告诉你的，还有心理上的准备。
As far as psyching in, I used to sit out here on the front porch sometimes up to 3:00 in the morning, 4:00 in the morning, because it's just me and the falls. It's rumbling. Like I said, I'm only a half mile away. And it was so quiet. Now sometimes if the wind is right, the breeze is right, it carries the mist all the way down the gorge. You can see it's like a white wall that goes down the gorge. OK? I'm sitting there. And all of a sudden, there was this little finger of mist that left the mainstream of the mist, came over, and it hovered over the small [UNINTELLIGIBLE] across the street here. And it looked like two little fingers. And it was pointing-- believe it or not-- pointing right at me sitting there.
至于心理建设，我常在清晨3点、4点坐在前廊上，因为只有我和瀑布。它在轰鸣。正如我所说，我只住在半英里外。当时非常安静。现在有时如果风向合适，微风合适，它会把雾气一直吹进峡谷。你可以看到它就像一堵白色的墙落入峡谷。好的？我坐在那儿。突然，有一小缕雾离开了主体，飘过来，盘旋在街对面的[听不清]上。看起来像两根小手指。它指着——信不信由你——指着坐在那儿的我。
It stayed there for about 10 minutes. Then it finally, like a finger, as if you're just bending your finger back to the palm of your hand, it joined the rest of the mist. And that was it. Talk about getting in deep with this. It was trying to send me messages. And oh, god, what I went through mentally on this.
它在那儿待了大约10分钟。最后，像一根手指一样，好像你把手指弯回手掌一样，它又汇入了剩余的雾气。就是这样。谈谈如何深入其中。它在试图给我发送信息。天哪，我在这方面经历了多少心理活动。
The night before, I came home. I was out doing a normal job during the day, and then I came home, had something to eat, went to bed, fell asleep, and woke up the next morning. I didn't wake up, nothing like that. I guess I was so mentally prepared, psychologically prepared, that it didn't bother me. As a matter of fact, around my bed, I used to have pictures of Niagara Falls. I used to stare into them to fall asleep. I never had any bad nightmares or nothing like that.
前一天晚上，我回家了。白天我做着一份正常的工作，然后回家，吃了点东西，上床睡觉，第二天早上醒来。我没醒，没那回事。我想我已经做好了心理准备，生理准备，所以它没困扰我。事实上，在我的床周围，我常挂着尼亚加拉大瀑布的照片。我常盯着它们看以便入睡。我从来没做过什么噩梦之类的。
But next morning I got up, and Jeff was down. So we got everything together, the whole crew together. And the vessel was up at the crew chief's house. It was a great big state truck. And the barrel was on a special crib system on the truck. And I remember we climbed into it. And I will never forget the sound. And to this day, that sound remains in my mind. Them pounding those metal dog lathes. It was like being sealed into a metal coffin. And that was like, yeah, this could be it. This is your coffin.
但第二天早上我起来，杰夫也到了。所以我们把一切准备好，整个团队聚在一起。容器在工头家里。那是一辆大卡车。木桶在卡车上的一个特殊支架系统上。我记得我们爬了进去。我永远不会忘记那个声音。直到今天，那个声音仍萦绕在我的脑海里。他们敲打那些金属销子的声音。就像被密封进一个金属棺材里。那感觉就像，是的，可能是这样了。这是你的棺材。
That's good.
那很好。
So here we are. We're going down the road. That was the shortest two-mile trip ever in my life. We could hear each gear shift, each stop, each turn. I knew exactly where we were turning. And they went down Murray Hill and along River Road.
所以我们出发了。那是我一生中最短的两英里行程。我们可以听到每一次换挡、每一次停车、每一次转弯。我清楚地知道我们在哪里转弯。他们沿着默里山（Murray Hill）向下，沿着河边路（River Road）行驶。
Feels like we're going down Murray Hill. Uh-oh.
感觉我们要下默里山了。噢哦。
OK. She's straight now man.
好的。现在直了，伙计。
OK, good. Guess what?
好的，很好。你猜怎么着？
What?
什么？
We're [BLEEP] on River Road, I think now.
我们[哔——]在河边路上，我想现在。
No kidding.
没开玩笑吧。
55.
55。
Yeah, there we go.
是的，我们走吧。
And the truck pulled in, backed up. And they released the barrel, and they pushed it. And that's when it crashed into the water.
卡车开进去，倒车。他们释放了木桶，然后推了一把。就在那时它撞进了水里。
Uh-oh, Peter, we're there. We're there.
噢哦，彼得，我们到了。我们到了。
When you hit that water, this barrel weighing that much-- a ton and a half, when we hit that river bed-- it was about five feet of water-- it slammed into the floor of it so hard that it, like, jolted the mind. It was benumbing to the mind. And I thought, oh, my god, we didn't even go over yet. We just hit the river.
当你撞击那片水域时，这个重量级的木桶——一吨半，当我们撞击河床时——大约五英尺深的水——它猛地撞在底面上，甚至震动了大脑。这让大脑变得麻木。我想，天哪，我们还没翻过去呢。我们只是撞上了河床。
Then I'm looking out of the glass. And here's a bunch of seagulls floating over. And I'm looking out through the bulletproof glass. And what's in my mind immediately is that, oh, no. No, no, no. This barrel is freshly painted. There's people here with cameras and stuff. Please don't crap all over this barrel. That was in my mind. Meanwhile we're on a 25-second second countdown-- 25, 24--
然后我向玻璃外看。一群海鸥浮在上面。我通过防弹玻璃向外看。我脑子里立刻出现的是，哦，不。不，不，不。这个木桶是刚刷的漆。这儿有拿着相机的人什么的。拜托别在木桶上拉屎。这就是我脑子里的想法。与此同时，我们还有25秒倒计时——25，24——
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
[听不清]。
Sounds in the barrel were of course the two-way communication we had with our crew. Our crew chief had the radio, and he was telling us how many feet away we were from the brink. He was giving us a description of everything that was happening. And we had a stereo. That's a story itself. I'll tell you later on the story of how these fellows programmed the music.
木桶里的声音当然是我们与团队的双向通信。我们的工头拿着对讲机，告诉我们离边缘还有多少英尺。他为我们描述了正在发生的一切。我们还有音响。那本身就是一个故事。稍后我会告诉你这些家伙是怎么编排音乐的故事。
Well, I can say it. My barrel partner, Jeff, he says, guy, we got to have tunes in there, you know? And he's just quite a fellow. He said, you got to have tunes in there. And the tunes were, believe it or not-- the guys did a good job programming the tape. They should be music directors, I swear, at a radio station. As soon as I hit the river, the first song was "Riverboat Fantasy." Then the next song was "Dead or Alive" by Bon Jovi. You know, after we go over. I mean, these guys, what a warped sense of humor.
好吧，我可以说了。我的木桶搭档杰夫说，伙计，我们得在里面放点曲子，你知道吗？他真是个特别的家伙。他说，你得在里面放点曲子。信不信由你，曲子就是——那些家伙在编排磁带方面做得很好。我发誓，他们本该是电台的音乐总监。我一撞进河里，第一首歌是《河船幻想》（Riverboat Fantasy）。下一首是邦乔维的《生死攸关》（Dead or Alive）。你知道，在我们翻过去之后。我是说，这些家伙，真是扭曲的幽默感。
We're going down, Peter.
我们要下去了，彼得。
[BLEEP].
[哔——]。
We're going down.
我们要下去了。
Now, prior to doing the falls, I always thought it'd be something like a fast elevator ride, super fast. You know that feeling you get inside, real queasy, like, whoo. No, not at all. Not at all. And we did a 360 back flip, and I didn't believe what I was looking at because it felt like you lied down on the couch and went to bed, lying perfectly horizontal. And it was peaceful. It was so peaceful. The serenity, even with the music-- for three and a half seconds.
好吧，在翻越瀑布之前，我一直以为会像坐快速电梯，超级快。你知道那种感觉，非常恶心，像“呜”。不，根本不是。根本不是。我们做了一个360度的后空翻，我不敢相信我看到的一切，因为感觉就像躺在沙发上上床睡觉，完全水平。而且很平静。非常平静。宁静，即使有音乐——持续了三秒半。
After three and a half seconds, though, we hit, yes, that rock that was the size of a house. Hit the side of that. Water blew in at the same time. Then we went under the surface, hit two more times. And I can remember it shifted the barrel. It twisted it like a 180 in a circle. I remember we hit two more times. Everything went kind of translucent, white, darkest color. Then of course we hit two more times, then it surfaced. And then it was all over.
三秒半后，我们撞上了——是的，那块房子大小的岩石。撞到了侧面。水同时涌了进来。然后我们潜入水面以下，又撞了两次。我记得木桶移位了。它扭曲了一个180度的圈。我记得又撞了两次。一切变得半透明，白色，最深的颜色。然后当然我们又撞了两次，然后它浮出了水面。然后一切都结束了。
I remember Jeff yelling out, we did it. We did it. There were a few profanities here and there, which I won't say right now.
我记得杰夫大喊，我们做到了。我们做到了。中间有几句脏话，我现在就不说了。
Whoo-hoo! Whoo! We're OK! [BLEEP] right we're OK! Peter, what a [BLEEP] buzz, eh?
呜呼！呜！我们没事！[哔——]是对的，我们没事！彼得，真是个[哔——]刺激，啊？
We [BLEEP] made it, man.
我们[哔——]成功了，伙计。
Put her there bud!
握个手吧，兄弟！
But when we came out of the barrel, I can tell you, we were able to climb out of that thing right at the base of the falls, right at the bottom of Table Rock, the lower observation deck. And I tell you, because you're so sealed in that thing, when those hatches were opened up, that was a nice vision seeing the crew chief's face sticking in the hatch and it was opened up. And what a feeling when you climb out of that thing. And of course people are applauding all around, and the crew's got big smiles on their face. And you're literally looking straight up-- we were that close to the base-- at what you had just done and went over that magnificent beauty.
但当我们从木桶里出来时，我可以告诉你，我们能够在瀑布的底部爬出来，就在桌岩底部，下观景台。我告诉你，因为你被封在那个东西里，当那些舱口打开时，看到工头的脸伸进舱口真是个不错的景象。当你从那个东西里爬出来时，那种感觉真是太棒了。当然周围的人都在鼓掌，团队成员脸上带着灿烂的笑容。而你正字面意义上抬头直视——我们离底部那么近——刚才你所做的一切，翻越了那壮丽的美景。
After the stunt, I had never went down there. Six years, seven years. I live no more than a half a mile from it too. That's ironic about this, that it's hard for me to believe that I've done that, bottom line. It seems like a dream, like that wasn't me that went over. It was somebody else.
特技表演之后，我再也没下去过。六年，七年了。我住的地方离它不超过半英里。这很讽刺，很难相信我做了那样的事，归根结底。这就像一场梦，好像翻过去的人不是我。是别人。
You know, to this day, though, I don't try to act like a smart ass, like, yeah, we did the falls. Yeah, wow, super stunt men here. No. Not at all. I have the admiration that, thank you for letting it happen because it let us through. Whatever forces there were, whatever happened, I was allowed to do that. And she let me do it.
你知道，直到今天，我并不试图表现得像个聪明人，好像，是的，我们翻越了瀑布。是的，哇，超级特技人在此。不。根本不是。我心怀敬意，谢谢你让它发生，因为它让我们通过了。无论是什么力量，无论发生了什么，我被允许那样做。她让我做了。
Well, the program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder, senior editor Paul Tough, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Laura Doggett. Original music by Carrie Biolo and Jen Paulson. David Kodeski's stories were adapted from his one-man autobiographical show, Niagara . He's now working on a play called, I Can't Explain the Beauty .
好吧，今天的节目是由爱丽丝·斯皮格尔和我本人制作的，还有南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder），高级编辑保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough），特约编辑杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）和顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。劳拉·道格特（Laura Doggett）提供了制作帮助。原创音乐由凯莉·比奥洛（Carrie Biolo）和詹·保尔森（Jen Paulson）创作。大卫·科德斯基的故事改编自他的自传独角戏《尼亚加拉》。他现在正在创作一部名为《我无法解释那种美》的戏剧。
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this or any of our shows, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or if you don't want to write down the phone number, just visit our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can order a tape or you can listen to our programs there for absolutely free. That's right, free. Again that's www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. This American Life comes to you from the city of Chicago, Richard M. Daley, Mayor.
如果您想购买本节目或我们任何节目的卡带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。或者如果您不想记下电话号码，只需访问我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，您可以在那里订购录像带，或者完全免费收听我们的节目。没错，免费。再次重申，网址是www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（Public Radio International）发行。《美国生活》来自芝加哥市，市长理查德·M·戴利（Richard M. Daley）。
Funding for our program comes from the listeners of WBEZ Chicago. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who describes what it was like to listen to today's program this way.
我们节目的资金来自WBEZ芝加哥的听众。WBEZ的管理监督是托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他这样描述收听今天节目的感受。
It was like being sealed into a metal coffin.
就像被密封进一个金属棺材里一样。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。